We've talked about widgets and
user wallpapers, but
perhaps we're thinking too small.
We're still limited to
just a single device.
However, Android gives us the tools to
build a truly multi-device experience
through AndroidWear,
Android TV and more.
AndroidWear gives us ability to
really improve our notifications.
High-resolution backgrounds,
more information,
and even the ability to add
custom actions and layouts,
to give users a great experience
without pulling our their phone.
Taking it even farther, you can build
Android apps that run directly on
the watch, letting users
bring up your app on command,
say, right before deciding on
whether to pack that umbrella.
Or build a watch face to make
the weather information available
all the time.
Android TV opens up the other end of
the spectrum with a 10-foot experience.
This is where that great imagery and
easy-to-read information
can really be useful.
That's not counting the great video or
radar imagery opportunities that could
really make the big screen
experience amazing.
If you'd like to learn more
about all the ways to take your
app even farther and explore the myriad
of devices available to you, check
out the ubiquitous computing course
which goes into these topics and more.